good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast
and
happy Friday Friday gotta get down on
Friday everybody is looking forward to
the weekend
weekend we're getting down on Friday and
we're looking forward to the weekend I
actually have a very big weekend plann
I'm excited to share when I'm done with
my weekend because right now not much to
share but I feel like at the end of the
weekend I'll have a lot to share I feel
like you don't even know what my weekend
what the hell are you talking about oh I
will talk offline but I have a big
weekend okay like what are you doing
going
camping no but that's a good idea and
like honestly take them camping in the
backyard like they won't remember they
won't remember it so don't go out of the
trouble of like no and that would
actually be really cute to camp in the
backyard wait what is Jackie doing this
weekend have you told me I think so but
I mean I've definitely told you but but
maybe not in like the last 48
hours no I have no idea well we'll talk
later but I just I have an exciting
weekend planned and I'm looking forward
as as you so beautifully sung
everybody's looking forward to the
weekend weekend I first of all today's
episode is audio only for a multitude of
reasons one it is a blizzarding in New
York and my ass was not leaving the
house like no shot got it also woke up a
little sick woke up a little sick I know
we spoke too soon yesterday when I said
you were sounding like regular
roll then most importantly my delivery
window for my 9 to 12 crat and Barrel
delivery uh they were here at 8:40 we
live for timely kings and queens prompt
everything was delivered it was like the
crazy like I never saw three people move
so fast in my entire life like it was
like who where do you want this oh ho ho
and everything's here now amazing it was
so everything came so good but like
there's so many other things that I'm
waiting for like have another Crate and
Barrel delivery in like a few weeks and
then another CB2 one and now I just need
those to come like I'm getting I'm
growing impatient you know it's a
waiting game you have to exert a lot of
patience ain't for the faint of heart
and I feel like Craton Barrel is pretty
immediate you know they have things in
stock it's not like and I usually only
order in stock items right but there are
people there are things that you order
that take like six months no I know one
item of mine was custom so that one will
be a while but I try to avoid like if it
ain't in stock yeah Furniture wise like
any furniture store I'm just that's not
for me I I'm not one of those people but
then like it makes you appreciate the
wayf fars where it's like you could have
this in three days yeah but like it
looks like it you know yeah no but
you'll have furniture no but then the
last time that I was in a pickle like
this like when me and Ben moved into our
last Department we were Furniture
shopping and we really wanted this couch
and beige but this the gray one I went
through this this exact same thing the
gray one was available like tomorrow the
beige one was like 7 to 14 weeks or
something like something really nuts and
we were like no way and we went with the
gray one and I loved the couch but I
always wished it was beige and if my fat
ass had just waited seven weeks like I
had the couch for 5 years literally same
when we got the couch we could get it in
Gray or beige but like the idea of
custom ordering I just know who do I
think I am yeah no no it's like is this
the Buckingham Palace you know and it's
like the gray one wasn't even tomorrow
it was a few weeks and then the other
one was like months months so no thank
you we got the gray one and what's so
crazy is now in this house we needed to
get a new couch and we wound up getting
the same couch in beige correcting the
error finally and the wait wasn't even
that long we bought it on Black Friday
and it came in February no The
Perils of buying furniture but the
benefits but the benefits today I reaped
the benefits I have so much more
furniture in my home still need more
stuff but it's it's starting to look
like a home that feels like a home you
know like a real home right that's all
you can hope for it's so true and we can
also hope for and celebrate the fact
that it's Friday we have a great show
for you guys we have Queenie and weenie
of the week we will not forget did you
write yours down I don't have them yet
I'm hoping they'll come to me over the
course of the episode I was thinking
about the week at a glance and the
stories but nothing really stuck out yet
yeah no I heard read something on Tik
Tok this morning actually that is my
weenie of the week oo exciting so like
you guys don't even know it yet oh my
gosh we're in the dark so we've got a
great show if that's all like should we
Usher these kids into the weekend I
think that we should Usher them they
deserve to be ushered and to know what's
going on and to embark on their weekend
I hope everyone has a great weekend
planned you know I think we all have
great weekend plans good it's just like
a nice cozy January weekend it it's a by
the way especially in like the Northeast
I think it's snowing in a lot of places
it's like so cozy it's like classic
weekend you know it's giving
weekend right is there a dumber
conversation like is there a dumber
conversation no but let's
try no but you guys know what we mean
though that's what I love ging weekend
yeah it's giving weekend it really
really is so without further Ado here
are the fast five stories that you need
to know and the fast five stories that
you need to know are brought to you by
skims we've been wearing skims for
months I love their bras I think it is
so worth the hype I think it's actually
under hyped the fits everybody T-shirt
bra which is a bra that I found on Tik
Tok a while ago it is the best T-shirt
bra I've ever owned I suffered from a
lot of back problems and I actually went
to physical therapy and then I ended up
getting a new bra and I found most of my
back problems to be fixed and the bra
was the fits everybody T-shirt bra from
skims I love it it's very full coverage
like I like my my boobs to be covered
lifted and I got got real boobs not you
know not I don't have fashion boobs
that's what they call them no I need I
need a forklift to keep these babies
alive and skims braas are made with
Innovative technology that give you the
best shape and support plus every bra is
designed with the comfiest and softest
materials so you feel like you're
wearing nothing at all they offer a
complete system of bra Solutions at
skims for every need and style and one
of the many reasons people love them is
they are super size inclusive especially
when it comes to bras they are available
in 62 sizes so they start at 30A and
they go all the way up to 4 6h believe
the hype skims has over 100,000 F star
reviews for a reason skims bras are now
available to shop at skims.com plus
you'll get free shipping on orders over
$75 if you haven't yet be sure to let
them know that we sent you after you
place your order select podcast in the
survey and select our show in the drop-
down menu that follows and if you are
looking for a gift for your Valentine or
for yourself skims just launch their
best Valentine shop ever also available
at skims.com and I believe that's a
story today right it is a story today I
was thinking that Synergy vertical integ
ation today's episode is also brought to
you by hellofresh whether your
resolution is to save money eat better
stress less hellofresh is here to help
you with all three say hello to your
most delicious year yet with fresh
ingredients and Chef crafted recipes at
a price that you'll like delivered right
to your door so each hellofresh box is
packed with farm fresh ingredients and
everything arrives pre-portioned right
to your doorstep for less hassle and
less wasted food so I'm new to the
hellofresh game and I feel like you Marg
and Olivia are always doing it and I'm
like yeah sure whatever I I actually
can't do it everyone knows like I could
mess up a bowl of cereal like I just
cannot cook anything to completion if my
life depended on it I'm inept however I
just made this like paprika chicken and
rice from hellofresh and like I actually
did it like I did it everything was
chopped normally I seasoned everything
it was so easy like you actually it's
pretty much idiot proof it's it's so and
it's great for novice chefs like you who
need a stepbystep Direction but it's
also great for experience chefs like I
was thoroughly Eno enjoying watching
benad hello fresh hello but it's so true
fresh also um I feel like a lot of
people's resolutions is to at least for
me like I really want to stop ordering
in so much A lot of people want to save
money eat healthier and Hell fresh is
just a great way to do that they also
have um wholesome Health forward options
like their uh calorie smart options
their protein smart recipes each week
and they say that breakfast is the most
important meal of the day and hellofresh
agrees so they're giving all their
subscribers free breakfast for life
which means you'll enjoy a totally free
breakfast item with every single
hellofresh delivery and that's worth
waking up for so go to hellofresh.com
toast free and use code toast free for
free breakfast for Life One breakfast
item per box while subscription is
active that's free breakfast for life at
hellofresh.com toast free with code
toast
free hellofresh America's number one
meal kit no what Ben came up with a
better slogan for them oh he did in his
video what was it hello fresh that's
funny it was making me chuckle I'm so
glad yeah no I could watch videos of Ben
chopping
like ASMR style I find it so impressive
oh wait by the way I know you don't have
Tik Tok but I don't know if you know
that like the queen of chopping and like
healthy chopping and like salads is
baked by Melissa the Cupcake Queen she's
on reals she's on reals and she just
released a cookbook by the way and it's
like all of her big salads I saw feel
like you should get it I actually have a
copy cuz Ben is um like moderating an
event with her and I feel like it's so
you and Olivia like big big salads I
love big salads and I like her content
and I it's very like aspirational but I
just feel like she makes it look easy
but when you break it down like it
doesn't look easy like looks like very
hard but she's the skilled at it you
know but it would take me like an hour
amazing amazing Chopper yeah it would
take me an hour to make what she calls a
10-minute meal no and then like I like
she always starts the video with the
salad being done and she's always eating
salad off a chip like that is so unique
that's something you would do if you ate
salad though yeah like instead of a fork
she uses a like a Tostito you love
eating off a chip I love by the way who
doesn't no Everyone likes a chip but
like you will eat you eat like rice off
a chip taco meat chili like everything
okay I don't know if I eat rice off a
chip you just like eat off a chip which
is why it's so surprising that you don't
like you're get confused you're getting
confused tacos what you're thinking I do
with chips I do with
rice no no no you do both
things but the I think I'm going to take
out oh I know I said I was going to go
on a chili fast until the SE Bowl but
it's such a chilly day treat yourself
turd but Ben's not here I'm going to
have to make it myself it's goodness
gracious I know like help yeah no don't
do it order in okay okay okay get chili
from like PJ Clarks or something or wend
no you know what has good kosher chili
what mocha Burger Ben got it the other
day done done I think it was Turkey too
yum
okay let's get into the stories our
first story you know in light of the ads
that you shared lad Del Ray stars and
skims is new Valentine's Day campaign so
skims always on the pulse and their
Valentine's Day collection came out Lana
Del Reay is the face of it not only is
she Lana Del Ry but she was in the news
this week because of Coach Ella so it's
so it's everything's coming up Lana Del
Ray this week no they really kill it
like there's never been a campaign that
isn't like so on point I feel she's also
like so and the vibe of it which was
like very retro like heart-shaped bed
it's so Lana Del re no it the images are
truly stunning and beautiful and
creative artistic and makes you want to
buy what she's selling and I think a lot
of people are quaking about this cuz
Lana's like lowkey really close with
Taylor Swift they did snow on the beach
and they both are like connected through
Jack the beach Jack antinoff and like
this is now the second collection like
britty Mahomes and Lana Del re where
it's like Taylor's best friends modeling
for skims now I don't think Lana's her
best friend and with britty Mahomes I do
feel like she shot it before she ever
even met Taylor but it's still
interesting I feel like the Britney
Mahomes was more of a Smoking Gun than
this and as we've stated like Kim has no
problem reaching out to Taylor's friends
and being in Taylor's world it's Taylor
yeah of who will
never and she also like these are her
friends and they might not be like her
bestest friends in the world who you
could like I could say my bestest friend
on Earth tury you can't talk to this
person can't work with this person but
my wider network of friends you can't be
so controlling and I think Taylor is
that way as well I
agree yeah so beautiful stuff happy
almost Valentine's Day that snuck up on
us but wait I'm sorry back to the Taylor
and Kim thing cuz like that's my Roman
Empire it really is Kim like the last
time she spoke about it was on watch
drins live and Andy was like what's the
status with Taylor Swift and Kim was
like over it it's done but she didn't
say that they ever spoke Kim was just
like I'm personally moving on from this
but it wasn't it wasn't her thing to
move on from she wasn't the one who
needed to move on no and Taylor is still
here still at the
restaurant still sitting in the corner I
haunt yeah that's her and she'll always
be there there's no way out for them
that's her Roman Empire too yeah like
that's her cancellation she was just
talking about in her Time Magazine thing
like it's not happen no and by the way I
find this a lot um with people who have
gotten canceled people are always like
get over it it was so many years ago
like whenever I see like a clip on Tik
Tok when somebody asked Sophia Franklin
about like her thing they're like oh my
God this girl's still talking about like
how can you not like we talk about ours
all the time and people are always like
get over it get over it you literally
you have to experience it to understand
you guys you never get over it like it's
so crazy you never get over it and there
are some people whose theirs is just
like bigger you know like Sophia
Franklin will never get over it should
never get over and could never get over
it because what happened was crazy and
huge not even just the like it was
everywhere it was like in the New York
Times but what happened from there like
Spotify million of course she's not over
it never going to get over it but there
are people who get canceled along the
way and I think it's you know it's
always going to be like a part of them
and a part of their story but it's not
at the level of like Sophia Franklin or
even like Taylor Kim reputation that
like a year off a whole year of not
working like you're not [__] getting
over that I'm just never going to be one
of those people to be like stop talking
about it get over it like I get it it's
literally traumatizing no I yeah I guess
anyone who's been through it would never
think that way no and like all the
girlies who get canceled like they do
come to me you know for advice and such
and I always say they're like when will
it go away I'm like girl never but like
you just learn to live with it and like
eventually like becomes funny like yeah
no it hardens you for sure and you're
really not anybody until you've been
cancelled no it's so true and then I
always say like think of anybody you
would admire like they have a scandal
like you're fine you're literally fine
yeah I kind of feel like this weekend I
want to watch Traders what's that it's
the peacock show where they take like
villains from different oh tra tours
sorry I thought you meant like Traders
like tra Flor of the stock exchange yeah
yeah I thought it was like a documentary
about Traders apparently this season has
like broken all sorts of records and
ratings it's like apparently amazing and
I think that's a good thing to watch
while I'm sick super cute but they're
like waiting for episodes like it's not
all out yet
excuse me oh okay annoying annoying well
I just had a really great segue so I'm
going to go back to that moment I'm so
sorry because like speaking of you know
former scandals that you can't live down
Kelly Osborne has given an interview to
Rolling Stone I'm obessed and she's
talking about a lot of things so first
of all she's talking about being a nepo
baby and she's being we don't care
that's not what we care about feing with
pride well I I liked her what she had to
say she said I'm a [__] neppo baby
and I'm proud to be a neppo baby I'm
proud of my parents achievements I think
that what they have done is incredible
history making I go so far as to say
both of them are iconic but it doesn't
mean that I should automatically be
given all of these opportunities my
parents have taught me that you have to
prove
yourself okay I actually agree I like
her ownership of it but I do feel like
she's been giving all these
opportunities like I don't know what
opportunities she would have if those
weren't her parents not only that like I
don't know what opportunity she received
that she was even remotely qualified for
fashion police yeah and page six notes
she's tried her hard at several tried
her hand at several career paths
including music fashion and acting
correct yeah just a little shady there
and then elsewhere in the interview she
admitted that she was a self-righteous
little seaword for previously asking and
you know notoriously asking who would
clean the toilets Donald Trump if
Latinos were kicked out of the country
so she opened up about the comment which
has since been turned into a meme saying
her comments quote came out so wrong and
she feels as though this country was
quote built on immigrants speaking
speaking out now about the viral remark
she described herself as a
self-righteous little seword in the
video quote I hate it I hate it so much
because I look at it and I'm like you
think you know everything and you know
nothing nobody wants to hear your
opinion on this I feel very strongly
that Latin America I feel very strongly
that Latin American culture is the
backbone of America I believe that Latin
Americans are the hardest working people
you will ever meet so I feel like so
conflicted about this cuz like can you
imagine like you accidentally said like
I don't think Kelly osor is like a bad
person who like feels this way like can
you just imagine like saying something
unintentionally like really [__] up
and for years and by the way 10 years
later it's more popular than ever it's a
trend on Tik Tok is it yes people do
like they're making it their own so you
just replace like if you kick every
blank out of this country then who's
going to blank so people are getting
really creative like if you kick every
angsty teen out of this country then
who's going to smoke you a pot Donald
Trump like people are making up their
own it's mine that was a bad example but
like people are being really funny about
it I'll send them
to so it's like another wave of people
talking about this I'm like I do
sympathize with like your worst moment
becoming truly a Cornerstone of culture
like it's hard it's hard it is hard but
at least for her like she said that yet
it's a PE like people aren't letting it
go but I don't feel like she was ever
there was no ever like retribution I
don't feel like she ever got cancelled
or fired or any thing you know so even
now like we all joke about it but here's
Kelly Osborne in Rolling Stone no it's
so true you know there's not like it's
not like she's been punished so I don't
know what's worse to like be immediately
punished for your actions but then like
people move on or people don't move you
never were punished or had consequences
but people people don't move on that's
an
interesting two options I don't know and
like it must be really painful for her
but it's so funny no and I just need her
to like not get upset over it because
it's so funny like yeah and the best is
like the way she pedals back like
everybody ends it after like Donald
Trump but then everyone's like uh no and
she's like no no in the sense that yeah
you know in the sense that you know what
I mean I didn't mean it like that come
on no it's so funny like honestly if
anything like I think it might have been
good for Kelly asor she's really like
cemented herself truly as a fixture in
culture because that thing will never
die it's getting more powerful as the
days go by yeah it's true and if she
wants to get back into music she could
like remix it back yes she tried her
hand at music at one point but she could
like honestly same same yeah I know DJ
with no job no I released two iconic
songs I think I need to get back I need
to get back into music really do you
have more to say yeah it goes a little
something like this since nobody picked
up my my original song I'll just make it
myself I like being alone too much to
dance you honestly should make that song
I
know I know why did my mind go to DJ I
don't know you obviously don't think of
me as an accomplished musician which
means I have more work to do it yeah
it's not it wasn't top of mind i' I've
kind of like forgotten about toast
Ando W I haven't and millions of others
Millions no no but like I haven't
thought about it in a while it's more
like it like that was like honestly like
lowkey like such an iconic thing for me
to do iconic like we need anthems in the
culture in the show like and you just
you put out the song you wish to see in
the world exactly but anyways I feel or
you could do a remix of this then who
would be cleaning your toilets Donald
Trump trump Trump trump Trump trump
Trump trump chop chop chop chop CH chop
chop chop chop who's going to clean your
toilets no I'm crying
crying oh my God it's so funny
but I do I feel like a Tik Tok DJ has
definitely already done that oh you got
to find it and send it to me but I do
think her description of her self in
this clip is a
self-righteous she does see where is
Extreme but calling like that was the
energy of the comment just extremely
self-righteous and it's clear that she's
self-aware and yeah that's all you can
hope for so no it's true and like I
believe she's changed I don't think
she's like a crazy like anti- Latina
Queen no no she was just like a brat who
thought she was like making a point and
she was not actually yeah and in trying
to like call someone else racist she was
being incredibly racist racist yeah it
was giving pot Kettle yeah but and I
feel I I do feel for her that she will
likely never live this down she will
will never and honestly she needs to
learn to live with it because it's not
going away so like she needs to I don't
know like go to therapy or sometimes it
can feel you know great to like take
your power back get in on it you know
something yeah that's what I'm saying
like to make a song out of it maybe
exploit it so much that people get sick
of it that's always a good strategy
exactly but I just don't see a I don't
see a world in which I'm ever sick of
this I know but what if like she really
like ruins it it's a good straty I'd
like to hear an interview from some of
the other women at the
table who were there and like what was
going through their
minds yeah well I mean they talk every
day those women so but I don't think
some of
like half of them are on the show still
yeah I guess it was a really long time
ago yeah I think it was like Rosie
PR yeah but the other one is still there
Joe joy and uh whoop oh yeah they're
always there they're always
there okay well sadly we have to move on
from this story but I we never truly
will but we're still here yeah we are we
and we will continue to be here if
you're if you're looking for us yeah
we'll be right here we'll be right here
our next story Madonna has been sued for
false advertising after starting her
Brooklyn concerts two hours late Matana
Matana Matana greater Matana Madonna and
Live Nation have been sued by two fans
for false advertising after she started
her shows late concert goers Michael
fellows and Jonathan Hayden argued in
their class action lob suit obtained by
TMZ Thursday that Madonna was not
punctual during her celeb tour stops at
barklay Center in Brooklyn the
performances were supposed to start at
8:30 eastern time but the singer did not
take the stage until 10:30 p.m. eastern
time they claimed she showed up late to
all three of her shows at the New York
venue which took place in December 2023
in the suit the plaintiff state that the
late start constituted quote a wanting
exercise in false advertising negligent
misrepresentation an unfair and
deceptive trade practices they are suing
for unspecified damages these are two
[__]
losers um like wasting their time and
money like it's really annoying and it
actually is rude that Madonna makes
people wait like I don't care who the
[__] you are like people paid to be here
they got sitters like you're a pain in
my ass having said that like putting
together a class action lawsuit like you
need a hobby you need a hobby you need a
life like this is some of the most
losery Behavior I've ever witnessed in
my life yeah also it was on a week night
so part of their complaint is that they
had to go to work the next morning but
if they truly like had demanding jobs
they wouldn't have time to be doing no
but they have all this such as this
right they have all this time and money
for litigation like please yeah I mean I
guess we'll see how it pans out like is
this really cause for a suit and if not
and they lose don't they have to pay her
legal
bills yes I just don't uh oh spoolie is
back I yes I don't think that they'll
win well I feel like they think they'll
win if they're doing this unless they're
just doing it for attention classic
classic like I I get that doing
something for attention like that I
relate to yeah I feel like they must
have some sort of case I look for I I'm
interested to see how it plays out like
what are the legalities here is it false
advertising yeah you know then it would
like set a precedent for like every
performer but even the performers like
it says 7 o'cl but you know the opener
right but there is a show that starts at
7 yeah I guess that's true
interesting sort of if you're loserville
weenies of the weak contenders oh let me
write that down I actually completely
agree those freaks suing
Madonna are you ready for our next story
it's number four so I feel like you're
not oh my God no I'm not thank you how
did you know that about me I can read my
turd my turd my turd my turd reading
about my
M
okay today's episode is brought to you
by signos and the signos program where
you can get access to your continuous
glucose monitor and have it mailed right
to you so the CDC estimates that there
are approximately 96 million American
adults more than one in three who have
pre-diabetes and of those with
pre-diabetes more than 80% do not know
that they have it and that matters
because foods with high high carbs raise
your blood sugar more than other foods
during digestion the pancreas can
produce insulin and that binds the sugar
in the blood and takes it into the cells
as a source of energy so when insulin
retain resistance occurs it can be the
number one cause of pre-diabetes and a
healthy weight allows insulin to work
more efficiently and can help you keep
your blood sugars within a normal range
a healthy diet and regular exercise are
the best way to bring your blood sugar
levels back to a healthy range and
signos can help you short circuit this
cycle by using data directly from your
body to design a weight loss plan that's
unique to your lifestyle signos is the
only company that combines a CGM a
continuous glucose monitor with an AI
driven app to deliver realtime glucose
monitoring for Optimal Health and weight
weight management with signos you can
literally see which foods cause your
blood sugar to spike above reasonable
levels and get real-time alerts to do a
bit of exercise to bring them back down
so you'll be able to learn the
difference between stress eating and
physical hunger you might better manage
your energy throughout the day sleep
better at
night so signos removed the guesswork of
weight loss and provides people with the
tools and knowledge that they need to
develop healthier habits it combines
glucose data from the CGM with an AI
driven app to deliver realtime glucose
insights for Optimal Health and weight
management right now signos has an
exclusive offer for toasters go to
sos.com that's s g n o.com and get 25%
off select Plans by using Code toast
today that's sos.com code toast to get
25% off select plans today today's
episode is also brought to you by
Jackie's favorite it's Babble the best
way to learn a language it's emerged
living where the language is spoken and
using it every day but obviously that
might not be the card in the cards for
you this year you can still learn a
language the second best way and that's
Babel do a better you in 2024 with
Babble the science-backed language
learning app that actually works do not
pay hundreds of dollars for private
tutors or waste hours on apps that don't
really help you speak the language
babbles quick 10-minute lessons are
designed by over 150 language experts to
help you start speaking a new language
in as little as 3 weeks Babble is
designed by real people for real
conversations their tips and tools are
approachable accessible and rooted in
real life situations delivered with
conversation Based Teaching so you're
ready to practice what you've learned in
the real world their courses are really
convenient you can do them anywhere
sometimes they're fun you know they get
a little crazy they like different
little games um and it's just so great
something to have with you all the time
and I feel like learning a language is
such a great resolution it's also just a
great thing to do as an adult like
expand your mind learn new things if you
travel of course it's always great to
have a grasp on the language it's also
Al you know a little bit safer so
studies from Yale Michigan State
University and others continue to prove
Babel is better one study found that
using Babel for 15 hours is equivalent
to a full semester at college so a
special limited time deal for our
toasters right now you can get 55% off
your Babble subscription but only for
toasters at babel.com toast get 55% off
at babel.com toast that's
babbel.com toast rules and restrictions
May apply at babel.com
toast thank you la you're welcome our
next story a Wizards of Waverly play
sequel pilot has been ordered at Disney
Channel Selena and David Henry are among
the cast sir pilot for a Wizards Waverly
play sequel Series has been ordered at
Disney Channel variety has confirmed
original series star David Henry will
star in and executive produce the
potential series with original Star
Selena Gomez said to guest star in the
pilot and executive produce he will
reprise reprise the role of Justin Russo
she'll be Alex Russo
and that's wasn't there another brother
Jake T Austin yeah the little
one like here's the thing I think for a
lot of people my age like wizards of wly
place was their Roman Empire like people
talk about the finale like it was like
made them cry or whatever personally I
must have miss out on that chapter like
I was very much in that era of like
Sunny With a Chance Hanah Montana like
loved Lov loved never really resonated
with Wizards Of Way place so this is
actually meaningless to me and I guess
the only thing I really truly all is
happiness for those two people who host
the Wizards of Waverly Place recap
podcast cuz hopefully they're going to
get back to work in the show that shot
them to start them yeah or even if they
don't like there's another show about
Wizards like they can recap that
there're so much they'll be in it cuz
that one of the the hosts was Alex
Russo's dad and the other one was Harper
her best friend like they were main
characters yeah no but this is just all
around great for their podcast this is
like
surprising on everyone's count what will
the show be about it's going to be on
Disney Channel so it's like is it for us
the people who used to watch Wizards now
I'm going to be watching the Disney
Channel no but also I believe at the end
of the show spoiler alert like the whole
show was that the three siblings were
Wizards and then when they turned
18 there was this like competition
between them only one of them came out
of wizard like there was and you know
Justin was the smartest one and
everybody thought it was going to be
Justin Russo the oldest brother then at
the end like why everybody was crying he
like gives it to Selena or something I
don't is always the craftiest one like
it I would have think it would be she's
only the only wizard so if it's a show
where she's only guest Cameo and the
pilot doesn't don't we need her she's
the wizard you're a wizard Harry yeah I
don't know when you spell it out like
that it's pretty silly but now I have to
think like I actually Wizards W face
this is a good show and actually Alex
Russo's character was like very funny
and it was very cute C but I never like
loved it as much as say Hannah Montana
so now I have to put myself in the shoes
of like if Hannah monana yes were coming
back on the Disney Channel Miley was
reprising her role I would be so excited
except I don't know how it could be the
kind of show that we needed to be while
being on the Disney Channel right like
it's a show for kids I feel like it's
going to be giving Raven's home energy
where it's like Alex and her brother
have kids and like they're Wizards now
and they show up in a few episodes kind
of like Fuller house
yeah but how old could their kids be
Selena's
10 20-year-old she got
yeah no
no no no no never mind um but she could
play someone who's 35 that's
true I don't know or maybe they're like
teachers at the wizard
School classic what would you want to
hand Montana sequel to be see I don't
know cuz it's like so perfect in its
entirety but I would never turn down
like an opportunity but I think she's
like still
Hannah you're leading a double life like
she has kids who know she she's Hannah
but like her friends at their friends at
school don't know that their mom is like
the biggest star and so they like are
mean to the kids and they're like we
have VIP tickets to Hannah Montana and
you can't come but then like the kid
gets pulled on stage by Hannah Montana
becomes the most popular kid at school
but the kid doesn't want it CU they
weren't nice to her before that yeah
yeah wait I'm obsessed and Grandpa Billy
Ray gbr
obsessed Uncle Jackson Uncle Jackson
Aunt
Lily Uncle oliv probably Lily's probably
still living in the guest's house like
she was Loki a freeloader but okay go
off Queen and Oliver is troublesome
these days yeah I believe he was just
arrested for uh meth Mitchell
muso
yeah that hair that oh what would the
hair what would Jackson's hair be now
I'm obsessed with the ACT actor who
plays
Jackson he seriously like is one of the
greatest comedic actors of our time like
he was lowkey
hysterical and not just cuz we were kids
like I watch it now they even hadam
Montana movie like I chuckle like his
phical comedy was on point he's really
so funny and he deserves more I
completely agree like he should be on
SNL like dead ass I totally agree like I
feel like the industry has failed him I
completely
agree I'm trying to see what else he's
done no don't look it up because it's
nothing and it's going to make us sad
like high school music the musical the
series squeeze me who is he in
it I'm not
sure well that's what's coming to Disney
let's see if it actually happens it's
giving Lizzie MaGuire oh actually did
you see Lizzie McGuire made waves why
she wasn't went on Good Guys well yes
the person oh my Ben is obsessed with
laa K he interviewed her yesterday for
good guys and he was like [__] Randall
like he's obsessed like he just like
learned about this whole thing oh that's
an exciting place to be because imagine
remember how we felt like and also when
we were first introduced to L like she's
the coolest girl on the planet no
totally but wait oh the creator of the
Lizzie McGuire reboot that got like
booted did finally share what the plot
of the show was going to be and it was
so uninteresting I forgot it Lizzie's a
chef and Gordo's about to get married
and he's expecting a baby with some
girl Lizzy's the chef yeah thought that
was
weird
I thought that was weird for sure and
Lizzie and Gordo aren't together or or
is she stop the wedding yeah right right
right with her sh with her food right
where she's going to bring a knife with
her
Wares this cake is so tasty I think I
should Lizzy she gets hired as like the
caterer so like it's literally giv me
the wedding planner like she spends a
lot of time with the bride and groom
like making cakes and [__] yeah yeah
yeah and fall us back in love with Gordo
it doesn't sound terrible no it was a
movie or a show a show was supposed to
be like a series on who Hulu it's kind
of like not enough for a show I agree
and also like I might really be like
offending our core Millennial audience
but like Lizzie MaGuire like was that
[__] for a period in
time and that's it like it wasn't like
Hannah like or even for some people
Wizards Of Way really plays like it
wasn't brought with us like we left her
in adolesence it was kind of like the
dumbest [__] show on the planet like
yeah she was a moment in time exactly I
I
agree are you ready for our fifth and
final story yes it's a little food news
I feel like it's been a while a little
food news Subway introduces foot long
churos pretzels and cookies at stores
nationwide wait how do you make a foot
long cookie I'm looking at it tury and
it looks like a cookie that's in the
shape of a ruler thank you okay that's
the perfect descriptor like I know how a
PR a pretzel can be like cylindrical I
know how a churro can be cylindrical of
course oh the pretzels look good
honestly I feel like a a pretzel like a
soft Bak pretzel especially from a fast
food place is like so easy to get right
and there's nothing tastier yeah but
antan like kind of has a corner on the
market however um do you live near a
Subway because we should try these in
our mukbang the next time we should let
me do Subway near me search I know you
wouldn't know because you'd never step
foot in a Subway well I can't step foot
in because then I'll smell like it for
the rest of my
days but I can rest of my days could
pull up yeah there's Subways a plenty
Subway pull
up so yeah we should definitely mukbang
this foot long cookies foot long churos
I feel like we had talked about foot
long cookies and we already had like you
know a a story busing dialogue about it
a busing dialogue well I feel like
there's no should be the name of the
show thank you yes title today is busing
dialogue busing dialogue
I [__] what was I going to say I feel
like there's no I yeah I don't feel like
any fast food chain has kind of cornered
the market on
churros no not in my estimation not in
my day like I If you say like who has
the best nuggets like everything's been
covered chocolate chip cookies like who
even has a
churro I don't know
clot clot try I thought I'd try
something new I feel like I've said turd
so many times in this episode like oh my
God please do not call me clot like I
don't like that at all back to turd back
to you in the studio turd why didn't you
call me
Claudia back to you Claudia because I'm
not mad at you
literally
yeah I will definitely be trying these
churros what was the other one pretzel
and cookie they are available here are
the important Deets you need to know
starting January 22nd they're in a brand
new category for the brand
okay Claudia for CLA CLA for the fast
casual spot the category is called
Subway Sidekicks so cute I don't know
why they have to like make a thing for
everything like put men because it's
someone's job and they need to earn
their paycheck but like that should be
my job what would you have called it if
they came out with three desserts for
Subway
okay like so put on the spot they have
like hours of Team meetings about this
and I have two seconds no and you could
do better come on
what do they call it I mean for me it
would be Subway Sweet Treats but that's
just me no for me it would be Subway
sweet treat sweet treat by the way that
actually is better Subway sweet treat
versus Subway Sidekicks they also like
need to change the name of Subway
because it's giving Subway it's giving
rat rat energy rat don't run this Subway
we do that is so true we do run this
Subway once we once we pull up yeah in
the mom car I know you know what I was I
was UGL a minivan yesterday that was
driving in front of me no you weren't
and I was just like I'm sure it's so
convenient like ample space okay okay
okay okay stop I'm sure drive so smooth
and safe and now the thing is though
since I drive a Tesla I'll only drive a
Tesla for the rest of my life because do
you know how big a minivan is like you
could never it's a bus I need a Tesla
Minivan and I feel like because El tesl
well no the family Tesla is the model Y
which I have the model X is a little
bigger that's a family car yeah it's a
midsize SUV no they don't have like a
Wagoner Tesla David DOI I remember when
I used to watch his Vlogs had a Tesla
with a third row so the model X is a
little bit bigger than the model model y
it has those Batmobile doors which are
just a bit much I know and also like
really not what are you going to pull up
to like you know the kids playground
with Batmobile like but I've also heard
that the doors going up that way are
actually really convenient for getting
kids in the car and when it's raining
they act as a bit of a shield um yeah
I've heard they're actually like really
good for for that but it's I'm sorry we
need CC extra we have to Circle back to
the minivan and this is not a slight
against minivans cuz I know it's like
you need it like
you of course but and this is just me
being totally honest with the audience
and I know we have moms who who drive
minivans and I like respect they're so
fugly like but the thing is when you are
in the car you don't see what it looks
like and so everybody else has to suffer
through the eyes sore but you're
enjoying that you're in a literal
spaceship for kids it's no you're
literally in a hearse like it's so big
yeah and yeah of course moms need space
but like honestly lowkey minivans have
too much space no but like it's it's a
party yeah I mean I guess like I could
see you know with the TVs on the back of
the screen like it's it's classic child
stuff like going to the soccer game
changing in the back like I get it yeah
you have room for everything but until
there's Tesla minivan I can't
participate but I do think Elon with his
10 kids like should be giving us the
minivan of our dreams just like how we
reinvented the pickup truck with the
Cyber truck right d star minivan except
after reading the Elon book and he talks
about everything that he hopes to
accomplish in the future like we know
what's coming the minivan was not on the
docket unfortunately [__] there was no
mention of one [__] [__] so before we
wrap up we have remembered today that
it's Friday and that means our new
segment will be airing it's Queeny and
weenie of the week where Jackie and I
both nominate someone or something to be
the Queenie of the week and the weenie
of the week now of course the Queenie of
the week is somebody who did something
fabulous this week the name on
everybody's lips if you will weenie of
the week is somebody who did something
so losery it could be a person a place
or thing it's really up for
interpretation it is I'm just going to
briefly look through what the stories
were this week to see if there I'm like
missing something so my queen my Queeny
of the week is not a person it's more of
like a place and a group of people okay
and you know this one goes out to the
girls from
Detroit I feel like you know they were
really upset by what we said and they
could have you know they could have they
came for us but like they were lowkey
respectful about it like I didn't see
anything rude and when it comes to when
it comes to sports like when we get
stuff wrong people are so [__] rude
to us like get a grip and I felt like
the Detroit girlies were sad to hear
what we had said but they weren't
disrespectful and that's Queeny Behavior
it is I'm sorry I agree and people were
commenting like no this is Detroit's
time it's been 66 years and I just want
to say like we shall soon see you know
and and I yes we were right that one
time about the Kansas City Chiefs but
we've often been extremely wrong so I'm
very open to being wrong and if I'm
wrong I will eat my words no and I'm
writing for the 49ers if the time comes
where the 49ers are no longer in this
thing I will ride for Detroit they're my
backup team okay they are not Kansas
City no no what is what have the Kansas
City girls done for me you don't want to
see tailored storm the field oh [__]
yeah but by the way the Lions and the
Niners I believe are like in the same
league like so I think it could be like
lions vers Chiefs got it don't quote me
on that like do you think it could be
sharks vers Jets or no yes I do I think
it's actually entirely possible got it
who is your Queenie of the week my
Queenie of the week is ballerina Farm I
do think she'll win Mrs World she's
already our Mrs American not America by
the way and she's the Queenie of my
heart she is the most impressive woman
I've ever laid eyes on and I just want
to miss her many mles in the birth of
her child less than don't let the hater
stop you from you know doing your thing
no and she's just an inspiration to
millions and I'm one of them so she's my
Queenie honorable mention to chrisen
yuse who was also a Queenie of this week
major Queenie now my weenie of the week
is a man whose name you don't know it's
Adam
shefer okay and he is a sports reporter
who apparently was the first to like
leak Jason Kelsey's retirement thus like
ruining the moment for him and I found
out that he did the same thing to Tom
Brady and that's why Tom Brady unretired
just so he could make his like take his
own retirement and make his own woman
and apparently this little [__] Adam
shefer like has just a history of doing
this like it's like a pattern and he's
like a little bit of a prick so my weeny
of the week is Adam shefer for taking
that moment away from Jason Kelce I
don't think Jason Kel to do what Tom
Brady did and like do it all again just
so he could have his own moment but yeah
interesting yeah that's that's weeny
Behavior it's by the way it's literally
the definition of being a weenie mwb
major weenie Behavior mwe major weenie
energy so I guess my weenie it wasn't a
week full of weenies to be honest I know
which is so refreshing but my weenies
are going to be those men who are suing
Madonna agreed like you'll be you're
going to be okay okay just stop stop it
stop wasting people's time energy
resources Court appointments stop it
it's an abuse of the justice system yeah
but let's see what the justice system
has to say for itself you know right
maybe we'll be eating our words yeah the
wheels of Justice turn
slowly but the cogs work mighty fine is
that the second half of that phrase I
def I know like no I changed it but the
sentiment is the same I can never
remember the second half of it the
wheels of
Justice turn slowly
quote the wheels of Justice turn slowly
but grind fine I like yours better but
the cogs are what the
cogs work I forget what I said okay well
good thing we recorded it another one is
the wheels of Justice turn slowly but
exceedingly fine yeah that
works I actually don't know if I believe
that to be true but the wheels of
Justice slow but fine no I mean you
don't think it's
true not always it takes a while it
could take a very long while but
eventually not always the wheel turns
not always really what are you thinking
of in
particular you don't want to say I don't
know I'm just like not like not going to
lie I'm just like over this conversation
like you started it I was just like
complimenting your use of words you know
oh okay okay I I didn't know it was
going to turn into an interrogation
about like my thoughts on the legal
system I didn't know that no I don't
mean the legal system actually I
actually feel like the legal system
sometimes it doesn't I mean like in
public opinion like the truth coming out
sometimes it takes no no people are dumb
and ugly and the wrong people always get
screw like the right people the wrong
people always get screwed I feel that
way I actually agree with you thank you
when you put it like that and I have I
can think of a couple instances oh my
God I'm starving what are you going to
have for to
for lunch I actually think I'm going to
have soup cuz like I really don't feel
good is chili soup I know but I don't
mind because I ordered my soup from
Second Avenue Deli and they give you two
pieces of Hala with the soup and let me
tell you their [__] Hala is so godamn
good it's the best Hala period period I
sometimes order a whole loaf it's only
seven bucks yeah if you're looking for a
great Hala second AV you Deli I guess
like seven bucks for a loaf of bread
which is like the most basic food like
it used to be a quarter that's why
people make their own sourdough turty
listen I I cap it at hellofresh I want
to see turty in the kitchen making
sourdough someone's in the kitchen with
dirty someone's in the kitchen I
know well that's our show thanks for a
great week you guys thank you so much
for listening to the toast the millenia
Morning Show where we deliv the past
five stories that you need to know every
Monday through Friday on YouTube so
watching us on YouTube pleas subscribe
give this video a thumbs up we're also
available podcast found on
Spotify still St a beautiful setting
andly talented we are have an amazing
weekend I guess we'll find out what
Jackie's doing on Monday it's not a big
secret uh it sounds like it is it's
really not it's really really not well I
can't wait to hang up this recording so
I can find out what the [__] it is you
know what it is act it out for me like
do
Shades okay one second okay she's taking
your headphones
off what
oh oh oh oh oh oh I did not realize that
that was this weekend yep okay that was
a pretty good clue that was a good clue
so tune in Monday to find out oh oh wait
you guys are going to want to tune in
Monday what we're doing and what the
clue was oh my God love love it tune in
Monday you're not going to want to miss
this love you bye love you bye